Steve Alford with the third ranked team
in the country now 27 and three coach
joins us now hi coach how are you great
the coolest thing in your office is what
look around that be difficult obviously
a lot of family pictures Olympic picture
Pittsburgh Steeler helmet I didn't know
you were a Steeler fan oh yeah yeah I
grew up in Indiana when the Colts were
in Baltimore
oh okay so big Steeler fan but mostly
family pictures and all my teams I've
had 25 teams so they're all my wall as
well did you play football no early so I
got tackled hard thank you that was it
but did your dad realize that hey I got
something special here I'm not gonna let
you get you know hit or hurt playing
football not at that point because I got
tackled hard in sixth grade I learned
pretty early so it was before I was
really any good at basketball either but
I didn't like the tackling part so I got
out Larry Bird told me that I asked him
when he first got the green light when
he was allowed to shoot whenever he
wanted to and Byrd said in sixth grade
he was given the green light when were
you giving the green light to shoot
whenever he wanted to be the coach's kid
I'm grown up you know with basketball in
my life so my dad started a bitty ball
league in Martinsville Indiana when I
was in first grade so I learned shooting
on an 8 foot goal and you know that was
an exciting league I don't know if I had
a green light but I sure didn't I didn't
fall in love with the game path of it or
so what was it shooting that thing I the
most shots you ever had in a game high
school that I don't know either I don't
know I know how many free throws but
most free throws I had I was 25 for 25
in a game in my senior in high school in
the game I don't know how many actually
feel go to tips all right now we have a
out here your son great game last night
eight threes and here's the question who
is a better shooter right now today
between you and your son and I want you
honest now don't be coach Alford all
right I just want you to be Steve Alford
and there's some kid named Bryce who can
shoot it pretty well so who's a better
right now not eighty-seven comparison
seventeen so right now at the age of 52
what I've noticed I was the guinea pig
in 87 that's the first time the
three-point line was put in in college
so I didn't grow up with it I kids today
grow up with that line and I should be
the first to tell you that lines been
moved back since you know he calls it
the baby line that I got a shoot out at
99 but so it's gotten a lot different I
can tell you as you get older that line
gets further and further and further
back so today there's no question he's
worked really hard as as at his release
and I think that's where he's really
showed a lot of improvement as he gets
it off so quick and so high that I never
had that kind of release or that kind of
quickness on my release so I'll give him
the 3-point line but as far as the
15-foot stripe I'll still take that if
you shot free throws you would beat him
today absolutely but if I take that if I
took Steve Alford from 87 and Bryce
Alford from 2017 there you go and and
who do you think Bryce would say I think
Bryce probably would say he might say
him from the three-point line but I
think he's he's smart enough I'm told
he's I've told him for years that been
an 80% foul shooter 85% foul shooter is
much different than being at 90 it's a
much much different deal so I think he'd
probably tell you I get the free throw
and he probably gets the three-point
shot he can definitely shoot the three
with a lot more range than I ever had
Steve Alford UCLA head coach joining us
have you tinkered with Lonzo balls shot
at all
the whole then I was smarter than that I
was only getting for eight months unless
there's anything up at eight months I
leave that kid alone he's special dad if
you could see him every day like I get a
scene he's just he's so very special in
the last month with our defense the way
our defense has improved a lot of it has
been I think Juan Jose well Lonzo had
two steals last night on taxes he just
grabbed out of the air with two hands I
mean he does things every night that and
every day in practice that his
basketball IQ is off the charts his
skill levels off the charts and his shot
it's hurt somebody there they refer to
it as the Jim Furyk slaying it may look
a little unorthodox but an impact it Jim
gets his club square and I think Lazo
does a very good job when he releases
the ball he has it on the right side and
it looks good and it goes in so I'm not
gonna mess with that
he's the ball brother who plays defense
because the other ball brothers who are
coming to UCLA don't play defense Steve
[Applause]
talked about jello but though they will
it's just and those those learned that
as well it's just it's a very unique
style and it's up and down and and we've
embraced that style here obviously was
with Lonzo getting out into the open
floor they're just really gifted playing
at a high rate of speed they make and
you know Dan you can play fast but to be
able to play fast and make the right
decisions that's a whole other thing
I mean lonzo's got 227 v 274 turnovers
and we're playing as fast as anybody
country is so playing fast is one thing
doing it efficiently is a whole other
thing
well there's only three players in the
last 20 years to average at least 15
points seven assists and six rebounds
and Lonzo is one of those three players
Kyle Collinsworth from BYU and Darnell
Valentine a Denzel Valentine from
Michigan State those are the only three
players in the last 20 years to be able
to do that so
you get to see this on a on a daily
basis nightly basis
you know Fultz is pretty good as well
alright but I don't know if he didn't
play last night but here is a version
123 a game what did you see from him in
the first go-around with Washington well
he's very talented
can really score the basketball has got
good strength for a freshman and like
lines old high high skill set I guess
you know I thought I don't like making
comparisons to players but you know I
just know I'm around so more often and I
just see the impact though not only as
skilled so makes people around him
better and I think when you go from
being one of those really good players
to an elite player like I think Lonzo is
I think the difference is how you make
players around you better and he does
that and I'm not saying fault
doesn't have that ability to do that I
haven't seen that yet I've seen it at
Lonzo and that makes him very very
special but you being a scorer you
understand what that means for a team
but also to have so Alonzo ball it you
know you would have been false from the
standpoint of getting 23 and nightwear
as Lonzo ball is something that's
different in college sports college
basketball because most of these guys
feel like they're out for themselves
especially the one in donors well that's
again I think that separates Alonzo you
would never know he was one and done and
potential top top pick in the draft
you watch him practice he competes in
any drill that we do to win he's been a
terrific teammate he's been a very
humble teammate that is all about the
team and he knows he's not gonna be here
long and that I think is what really has
made him special and lots of the guy
that he'll beat you by getting five
steals a game they'll beat you by
getting ten rebounds a game
if you tell him to score Lonzo could put
up 30 if if that's what you want him to
do and you're not going to stop him from
doing that I just don't think that's his
DNA I think he enjoys the pass and
allowing somebody else to look good
that's what makes him a great teammate
but when you sat down with Lonzo and his
family they told you that he's he's
stopping through UCL
and that it was gonna be one and done
you knew that up front no no I don't
think that was I don't think that was
really ever discussed to be honest with
you I just think they come in June and
after about a couple practices you can
kind of assume he's not very long we
watched him over the last two years as
well and so we knew we knew in the
recruiting process that you know he
wasn't going to be in college long
that's the error that these kids are
growing up in now and some of these kids
that leave school early
you kind of shake your head at Lonzo
that's a little bit different because I
think he's elite I hate he's very
special house leaf today he's good I
haven't seen him today obviously but it
was just a sprain it wasn't anything I
think serious so we'll see what happens
on Saturday but we fully anticipating
being back for the pac-12 tournament
he's good he's very aggressive really
yeah he's he's a piece of talented kid
you know it's it's all about Lanza when
you see the highlights and then I tell
people watch a game and then you'll see
what Bryce does and I said Leif is
really really talented big men well he
really is did and I think there's been a
crisply and obviously ronzo is our key
and our engine that makes everything go
because of the way he plays but he's
also passionate the guys that make shots
you wouldn't be getting eight nine
assists a game if your passing with the
guys that can't make shots and you got
Bryce making a high-level shots
Isaac Hamilton to Aaron holiday Tommy
Wells hardly ever misses a shot that you
throw it to him you throw wrong to the
ek and he's making a high percentage of
those then you go stretch for and TJ who
he's making 63 percent of his shots 46
percent of his threes and he's a
double-double machine so we've got a lot
of weapons that you know complement what
and how ronzo plays I think well don't
screw up my bracket I ain't oh there's a
lot of people in Westwood Mel a say the
same thing so I hope I hope you're right
I hope we though Steve good to visit
with you thanks for joining us and good
luck this weekend I appreciate you
having me on there my wife's a big DP
groupie so watches your every more
huama work so I appreciate it Steve
thank you I appreciate thank you all
right Steve Alford there you go and that
female demographic I just kill coaches
wives jimbe times wife launches all the
time you know it's that's my that's my
wheelhouse right that's my demo coaches
wives yeah absolutely
they love this show can't get enough of
it by the way Steve Alford is courtesy
of Continental Tire Coaches Corner
if you're in need of replacing your two
tires make sure that you put them in the
rear of the vehicle not in the front
because you don't want to be breaking in
wet conditions and fishtailing there
Paulie for consistency it's best to
replace all four tires at the same time
thanks Dan for more information visit
Continental Tire comp no tire for what
you do the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience